bonjour notre minute wam est consacrée
aujourd'hui un rapport réalisé par le
muséum d'histoire naturelle et par le
cnrs et qui prouveraient la disparition
des oiseaux dans nos campagnes
cette étude point tout particulièrement
les méthodes de l'agriculture intensive
et l'utilisation des pesticides et des
engrais chimiques des produits déjà
présenté depuis plusieurs années
maintenant comme la principale cause de
la mortalité des abeilles
ce que nous rappelle le ministre de
l'environnement sur le réseau social à
l'oiseau d'ailleurs nicolas hulot parle
de présenter rapidement un plan en
faveur de la biodiversité en réponse à
ces attaques
de nombreux agriculteurs ont pu prier
des commentaires agri skippy lui nous
explique que la disparition des prairies
et des et a une incidence sur les
populations d'oiseaux et de mammifères
et que tout cela est lié au recul de
l'élevage
sept autres exploitants lui n'a pas
hésité à utiliser le hashtag fait que
news car pour lui l'origine du déclin
des oiseaux ce sont les prédateurs il a
sans doute lu cet article de la croix
dans lequel donc un coupable et désigner
un coupable à quatre pattes
le char qui représente une population de
près de 15 millions d'individus en
france est accusée de prélever le quart
des oiseaux présents dans nos jardins
mais il est bien précisé effectivement
dans cet article que pesticides et
pollution reste les raisons principales
de la disparition des oiseaux